Speaker 1: Okay, so check this out. When we first
heard about this absolutely horrible story of a
ten year old girl raped and impregnated in Ohio,
unable to get an abortion in Ohio because of the
law having to go to Indiana, the right wingers
started doing two things. One is they said it's
fake, the fake story, it's made up and none of it
is true. None of this is happening. No one's going
to Indiana. Absolutely not. And the second part of
it was saying, is it a crime to go to Indiana for
an abortion? We've got to find the doctor sending
the girl to Indiana. We've got to find the doctor
performing the abortion in Indiana. We need to
charge these people, which is a crazy reaction.
But let's focus on the first part, which
was it's made up. None of it is true. Well,
it turns out that it is true. And suddenly,
because the suspected rapist is believed to be
an undocumented immigrant, they've quietly these
right wingers who first said it was a fake story,
they've started saying, well, yeah, she had to go
to Indiana for an abortion thanks to that no good
illegal that Joe Biden let let into the country.
Now, first of all, I have seen no evidence that
this individual entered the country during
the Biden administration may be true, may not
be completely irrelevant to the story, but check
out some of these examples, Governor Kristi Noem.
Tweeted a week ago, Dana Bash tried to trap
me with a story about a ten year old girl
who got an abortion. I pointed out nobody was
asking about the pervert who raped that child.
Now it looks like the story was fake to begin
with. Literal fake news from the liberal media.
Well, it turns out that that story is
absolutely and completely true. And Kristi
Noem just called it fake for no reason.
There was no reason to believe it was fake.
There's a guy named Clay Travis, okay? He
has a radio show and he's on some Fox show.
He writes books and, you know, this type of thing.
Okay. He tweeted multiple times that the story is
straight up fake. Check this out. Everything Joe
Biden said here appears to be a lie. Ohio law.
Ohio, a law allows abortion for raped children.
And more importantly, there is zero evidence that
this actually happened. Tweeting again. Media
reports of a ten year old girl being raped in
Ohio and having to leave the state for an abortion
appear to be completely made up. Tweeting again,
Clay Travis rips apart Indy Star and the rest
of the leftist media for allowing the story
about a ten year old seeking an abortion to
go viral. Well, the story was completely true.
And now, with absolutely no egg on his face,
no embarrassment whatsoever, which he should
be feeling. Clay Travis updates the story and
says, updating this viral story, which you said
shouldn't have gone viral. A 27 year old illegal
immigrant in Ohio has been arrested for raping a
ten year old girl. The girl could have gotten an
abortion in Ohio under state law, but traveled to
Indiana to have the abortion instead. So now the
focus is, well, that's an undocumented immigrant.
Ohio Congressman Jim Jordan, who, by the
way, does not exactly have a track record
of reporting and taking seriously believed in
alleged assault of minors. But that's a story
for a different day. He deleted his tweet.
He posted another lie. Anyone surprised about
the story? And then that tweet has mysteriously
disappeared. Sorry, that tweet has been deleted.
They don't apologize. They instill fear and say
it's the left wing media that's lying to you.
They can't be trusted. They can't be believed.
The entire thing is made up. Then it turns out
they were lying and then they just move on to
the next thing. Now, here they have a little
bit of an escape chute because the perpetrator
the the alleged perpetrator is believed to be an
undocumented immigrant. If it weren't for that,
they would just be they wouldn't even talk about
the story. They now have a new angle, a new straw
to grasp on to, which is this is an undocumented
immigrant and it's Joe Biden's fault. And look at
the terrible thing that an undocumented immigrant
did. Well, you were just saying that it never
happened. And now the problem is a different one,
completely predictable. And again, they will very
casually say the story is fake, even when there
is no reason to believe that the story is fake.
It was very real. It's a tragedy. It's a result
in part of the abortion laws that these very
same people want to be, the laws in these states,
that's where we are and they just don't care. It's
the Trumpian approach. You apologize, you just
move on. You pretend you were never wrong or you
move on to something else, some shiny new object.
They do it every time and they're not going
to stop. We'll have more on these stories
on our Instagram, which you can find at David
Pakman show. Later on, we're going to look at
some incredible video of a Republican congressman
talking about post birth abortion, which isn't
a thing. I mean, it quite literally doesn't
exist. We'll get to that later on in the show